I'm in Phoenix Arizona on a mission eat
good Mexican food
discover new cacti and find out if
immigrants are stealing American jobs
for to believe this guy they are but
what do people here think do you think
that immigrants are stealing American
jobs
yes no I don't know I think we need the
immigrants we need their um we need
their help here so how do you know an
undocumented immigrants not gonna steal
your job maybe steal your bike steal
your honey not worried about it I guess
I can't agree but their politicians can
Arizona has some of the strictest
immigration laws in the country to
understand the immigrant labor economy
better I met up with Mesabi Barea okay
so we are gonna go to to hum depose that
are in this area he's an organizer who
heads up a local workers Center who
introduced me to some workers import
giving me sake a Phoenix I love Sofia
port okay policy to join America Medora
come oppose available if you're bound
for America but it hasn't always been
the dream imagine Ernesto and Danielle
have been living and working in the US
for over a decade and both are
undocumented no venimos ro bono tipo de
trabajo de no in Elmo's a trabajar con
elsewhere so way so nada Jornada un
trabajador de un bar Yarrow este de
empezar de como rita que esta el tiempo
el calor tratamos de estar muy temprano
cinco a la mañana a las horas Tomas
temprano en and ol else or when do we
take a break
in recent years things have gotten even
harder for these workers thanks to two
laws in particular the so-called show me
your papers lost and one that requires
employers to check a workers legal
status Iver fi SB 1070 como cambio alam
bateau de trabajo y como efecto a sous
sus comunidades a few algo muy muy duro
muy difícil de uno con Taymor en sus
casas para no sin simpler salir y sin
pensar que pensando que cualquier a topo
se pueden day
my soul we we do feature between 2009
and 2012 the number of undocumented
workers in Arizona fell by 40 percent
which caused the GDP on average to drop
by 2 percent every year some people say
that's okay the pie might have gotten
smaller but so-called real Americans got
a bigger slice of it but it also
affected employers like egg farm owner
Glen Hickman who says he lost legal
employees because they had undocumented
family members the whole family went to
some state that they felt was more
tolerant of immigrants SB 1070 hit this
community in particularly really hard in
a very negative way
Roberto Reyes owns a landscaping company
here in Phoenix he says Arizona's
immigration laws are out of touch with
economic realities I got to see a lot of
the houses we boarded up how did they
were abandoned and I don't think all of
them were abandoned because people
couldn't afford it there was a lot of
houses we went to that like stuff that
was very important to them they just
left in my mind someone like probably
got deported or they should have to
leave really fast and even though it's
law employers have skirted requirements
to verify a worker's immigration status
because now they can hire anyone as an
independent contractor as a workaround
so what it means is that I do not want
to have right to overtime to minimum
wage you know to training they're
basically their own employers and you're
not you're just giving them for a
certain amount of time or a certain
amount of work what would your company
look like if you couldn't hire any
immigrant workers I don't know we would
have honest work is work and not every
job is fulfilling sometimes it's just
hard and sweaty and dirty and those kind
of things so I think that we should have
a policy in the United States that
accommodates the need for those workers
that can come here work legally and when
the job is finished they can leave
what's your response to Donald Trump's
idea of building a wall to keep Mexicans
immigrants out of the US there's things
that call the ropes things call the
matter
and those foods can be used to climb a
wall really easily the problem
everything is something it's just the
reality the truth is wall or no wall
papers or no papers laws are no laws the
draw for immigrants to work in the u.s.
remains because compared to places like
Mexico the u.s. is still the land of
relative opportunity and that's just how
it is for now